Just woke up.
Togo and Chibi, they woke up as well.
And this is how we start our day here.
Look ... still dark.
It is 5:30 and I got to get ready.
Right, so I got my night gown on.
These lights are so strong.
The first thing I do is I need
to give Togo and Chibi some milk.
I got to make some coffee for me and Nikita.
Now while I'm making the coffee, I got to
take Togo and Chibi to go and do
their thing outside... pee pee.
Okay go go go go.
There you go Chibi.
Launch control.
C'mon Togo. Let's move, let's move.
Alright, Nikita, some coffee.
So this is how we start the day usually.
Me and Nikita very quick, just
connecting with a cup of coffee.
Cheers.
And with Togo and Chibi of course.
And then uh we usually read the Bible together.
2 Peter 1 verse 3.
This is beautiful.
His divine power has granted to us all
things that pertain to life and godliness.
Thank you Father for giving us life.
Thank you for giving us everything that we have.
Especially the things that we take
for granted that we don't appreciate.
Father, I ask that you be with us today
and help us to smell the flowers and see
the beauty in the life that you have
created but also while we do that,
please help us with everything we need to
do today` with the two YouTube channels,
the ministries and the filming this morning.
And all the meetings.
Father, we just want to move in
your will, so please help us.
In Jesus name we pray, amen.
Amen.
So I've got my gym clothes on because I'm going
to go to the gym after the morning meeting and
before the morning meeting with the DLM team
there's a few things I need to take care of.
A few priorities.
And so it's just much easier.
I try to go to the gym every single day.
The time that I do that's just
uh that's a little bit different,
depending on what I need to do that day.
Now, I also do a quick trim.
I just trim the hair and cut
it all off here on my cheeks.
Here on the sides and then also here on my neck.
This is the best water bottle.
I carry it with me throughout the day.
It keeps the water nice and cool the whole day.
And it also just helps me to remind
myself, hey, you need to drink water.
So this is what I do in the morning.
I have breakfast.
Just oats with some nuts.
Mixed nuts.
And then of course the blueberries or any other
kind of fruit. Sometimes I love bananas as well.
Sometimes I even throw in
there some peanut butter.
So this is it.
And then while I eat - oh,
and with white protein of course, if I work out.
And then while I eat I just go through the things
that I need to do in the day.
I schedule my priority list.
It's always things that you got to sacrifice.
Certain things that just are more important than
others and so for me, just running DLM Christian
Lifestyle, DLM Men's Lifestyle, a new company that
we're going to call Ruach Entertainment.
Disciple, well I can't speak too much.
There's a few other things as well
and so there's a lot of things that
sometimes require my attention before
other people can continue their work.
Like the editors.
I need to tell them what to do,
what to use and also sometimes I need to trim the
footage, which I will probably do in the next few
hours, maybe two hours before the meeting starts.
Thank you, Father, for the food and
thank you for this amazing day.
This is a day that you have made.
I will rejoice and I will be glad in it.
Thank you so much, and help me with the list
and everything I have to do.
In Jesus' name, amen.
It's so important to start your day the right way.
Breakfast is done.
Togo and Chibi are always close by.
There they are.
Oh man, the best dogs ever.
Well for me, they're not dogs.
They're like fur kids for me and Nikita.
For some of you who do not know Nikita and
I might not have any kids and if
that's God's will, it's His will.
I will be content with that.
But we are praying for kids,
so we'll see what happens.
Now I just want to
quickly explain to you something.
We're actually planning on moving to the USA.
Some of you already know that but in the meantime
we kind of let go of our house and everything and
now we live in this furnished place.
Somehow we got this beautiful
location and at a fraction of the cost.
There's a few things like we have to move out in
December months and certain months for the owners.
We can't use the garage.
There's a few other things that was
wrong with the plumbing and it's just
a lot but God helped us with this place
so that we can come here and film videos.
You can just hear all the bird sounds here.
And we're just working so hard that we don't
get a lot of time to really appreciate the place.
Oh... Togo and Chibi want to want to get out.
Oh Togo Chibi ... okay, come on guys.
Alright, so I'm drinking in every moment
that we stay here because the previous
place we stayed at was very small.
It's all we could have afforded and that was
more inside the city and there was just a lot
of noise and my goodness it's not that I'm
complaining, I'm just very very happy and
so so thankful to God for this place, that we
can record - film - videos when it's quiet.
You do hear a little bit of cars every
now and then you see them driving there,
but that's easy to take out with Adobe
addition, if it's the same noise, right?
And so I just wanted to share this with you guys.
Don't think we're rich at all because we're not,
but we got this place only through God
and so we're only going to stay here for a
little bit until we have to move to America.
And we're in the queue, we're just waiting
for the embassy here in South Africa or the
consulate to give us a date and then we can
go to the appointment and then we can get
our visas and then we can move to America.
So this is it guys.
This is my little studio here.
Where I sit and work most of the days.
If I'm not out filming or doing something outside
and then sometimes Togo is here wants me to
pick him up .... there we go.... okay okay okay.
I do have a little bit of time before the
meeting starts ... 2 hours ... so there's
a lot I can do in two hours.
I need to trim some footage.
I need to check some emails.
I need to do a lot of basic stuff and
just get ready for that meeting.
So let's get to it.
Ooo wow, that is beautiful.
It's going to be a beautiful day.
Daniel here with DLM Men's Lifestyle and
today we're going hunting in South Africa.
Alright, so this video is exporting.
And now I need to go and take my supplements.
Oh good morning Nikita.
Good morning.
Nikita is awake and she's working.
Good morning, hello.
Already at work.
Yep, of course, what's the time there?
I have a lot to do.
7:56 in the morning.
Nice, I like it I like it.
Give me a fist bump.
So these are my supplements, Sunday to Saturday.
Now one day, I might tell you and
show you everything that I use but
I'm not sick or anything, this is just
to keep me running and it's very good.
I'll add it in a video description for you.
One of the most important things
here is the Vitamin D.
It just helps you so much,
just having a strong body to fight any kind
of disease, getting a cold, or anything else.
Alright, so we got the pills and our guard
dog is barking here for something, Togo, what.
And Chibi is here as well.
What is it?
Ok relax, relax, relax,
buddy relax, there's nothing.
There's nothing.
What is it?
Is it the Opa?
Yeah, done.
So sometimes there's monkeys here.
And he really doesn't like the monkeys,
when I when he hears the sounds.
Come on, let's go.
Come on.
Let's go.
So that was just Caline now.
And that's Jaques.
They just woke up.
They're visiting us for a little bit.
Caline is doing all the social media
still in her pajamas and then that's Jaques.
Of course you know him already, the video editor.
And you know Caline.
She doesn't like videos at all,
so you'll see her jumping out of the shots
every now and then, which is strange because
last night she accidentally actually did a whole
Telegram live video accidentally by herself.
Alright, so Nikita asked me to come so
we can talk about a few things here.
Yep, and Togo is working with, yeah.
He's always working with.
There is Chibi.
So there's a few things we need to discuss.
See you guys later.
Right, I got 15 minutes
before we have the team meeting.
And that means I've got some time
to make some coffee.
Alright, now this is
the coolest thing to keep your coffee warm
because cold coffee is not good unless it's
iced coffee on a very hot day but this is going
to keep it warm for 3, 4, 5 hours maybe even.
Good morning, good morning, okay, let's pray,
Father, thank you so much for another day.
Thank you that we can just dig into your Word.
Please speak to us.
Amen.
There's another verse that says but we
should take all our thoughts captive.
Bring it under the obedience of Christ.
That's all I want to read today.
After that, he talks about the coming of
the Lord and it's interesting but I just
want to focus on this part where it's about
just living a life that's pleasing to God.
And just reminding us to control our
bodies meaning our flesh as well, you know,
the desires... everything that we want to
do. Bring it under the Lordship of Jesus.
He is now Lord, right?
We accept Him as Lord and Savior,
not just you get your ticket into heaven.
But you want to be the Lord of your own life.
Jesus is the Lord of your own life.
He sits on your throne, you follow
Him in this newness of life. Full stop.
Is there anything that you guys want to share?
I think something that stands out for me
is that it's your own responsibility to
build that relationship with God.
No one can live for you or pray
for you or read the Bible for you.
An important part for me is also
that Verse 11 - to mind your own affairs -
and to work... work with your hands as we
instructed you 'cuz they always stick their
noses in somewhere where they don't belong.
Stop looking into other people's lives
and, you know, focus on your life and your
growth and with the Lord, and your relationship.
And to work with your hands so that part kind of
goes into the next way that you can understand it.
For example, people always wanting to have
what others have but then they're not
willing to put in the work themselves.
The hard work, the hard
labor with their own hands.
And do the deeds, you know,
to get somewhere in life.
If we want our faith to be as high and as
strong as other people, why aren't we doing
that effort and and putting in that hard work?
I was also going to say also like with that part
where you know it's so easy to pinpoint in other
people's lives there's like, always wanting to
pinpoint in other people's lives like all the
little specks in their eyes, but it's like you
need to first take out the log in your own eye.
Thank you for that.
Focus on your own life.
The Bible does talk about busy
bodies and gossips - you guys are right
anyone else who want to share anything?
Yeah so it's just that part also that
Nikita and Janine just spoke about.
I think we need to talk less and
listen more sometimes and because
I think you need to be informed about
the things that's going on around you.
Aspire to live quietly.
Understand, so don't be the reason
somebody else stumbles and don't be the reason
somebody else gossips because sometimes a word
or a gesture or an eye roll can perhaps be more
than words and our actions, also, our actions can
speak louder than words. as that proverb says.
I always say I'm a work in progress understand
so I'm under construction so every day I take
it on God's grace and as you read and learn and
study God's Word I think it's it becomes easier.
But yeah, there's also that self responsibility
almost in yourself, understand, to abstain
from these things and the key in it is that you
can't do it on your own through our own efforts.
We will not be able to abstain of from anything
of this if we don't allow God to take the wheel
in a sense and guide us in everything that we do.
Thank you Danie.
That's good.
Anyone else?
I just want to say how fitting it is to the
newsletter that you literally sent us this week.
I've been reading it - it was a good message
because are you selfish or selfless and the
one part that stood out to me was Galatians
2:20 where it says I have been crucified
with Christ, it is no longer I who live,
but Christ who lives in me. For me that stands out
this morning is verse seven ... for God has not
called us for impurity but in Holiness therefore
whoever disregards this disregards not man but
God who gives his Holy Spirit to you.
Roman's getting ready.
I see him. I see him.
Here we go, here we go.
The important part for me is that the
sanctification is the will of God because sometime
we we miss this part because some teachings in
Nepal in our country some people are preaching
like we all are justified by God and now we are no
more sinner longer so we don't need to repent or
we don't need to live a holy life something like
that. But the true thing is we all are in a long
journey of sanctification. We grow day by day in
Christ and He changed our hearts and He wants us
to move on from one glory to another glory.
This is the very important part for me that
the sanctification is the will of God and
we need to live our life holy as He is holy.
That's it so thank you so much
Daniel for saying the Word.
That's good and so true.
It's so clear in the Word
like you say Roman and so when people don't
preach it it's just the devil is at work.
Yeah go on sin, don't worry about it.
Go on.
It's also verse seven and eight
that stood out for me today.
Caline, did you want to add something maybe
you've talked too much yesterday when you did
the accidental live video on Telegram so maybe
you've talked a lot already but in case you want
to talk a little bit more then go ahead.
I just have one thing to add and it goes
hand in hand with what Roman and Damon and
Leon also talked about ... about how they
are showing brotherly love for one another and
it says for that indeed is what you are doing
to all the brothers throughout Macedonia but
we urge you brothers to do so more and more.
So I think it's important to remember to not just
get comfortable with the position that you are at,
or in the the progress that you have made.
But to continue to strive to do better and
to please God more and more and to walk
in His will more and more and to love
other people more and more to spend more
time with God to get to know Him better.
Climb this mountain until until the day you die.
Right, so I agree and I agree with everything you
guys have said but I've got to ask you this.
It's easy to talk about these things... to
identify these truths... but what
are you actually doing about it?
Do you have a structure that you're working on?
Do you have a book you're working through?
Do you have a Bible study that you say
you're going to have a a habit to change
yourself and to grow holy?
What are you doing?
Are you making a list of all the things that
you know you should change in your life?
Are you making it a priority?
So what I'm saying is just
thinking about okay, this is my goal.
I want to be live holy, I want to do
this but just keeping it there and doing nothing
about it means you will never reach it because
you're still staying stuck.
You can see the truth,
you understand it, but you're not moving.
You're not doing anything about it.
So you need to create a structure.
You need to change your habit.
You need to do a lot of things to
actually start moving like Jaques says.
Don't stand still - you need to start taking that
first step and there's a saying that also says a
thousand miles starts with a single step.
You will say those single steps in a
lot of different things in your life.
There's different seasons, different times
and whatever God wants you to do of course
we already know He wants you to live holy.
But how do you do that?
What does He want you to do,
with editing, family, who you marry...
there's a lot of things in your life, right?
But in all those things, you need to step
that first step with the Holy Spirit that
helps you to go the right direction
because you're not alone anymore.
As Janine said, my life is Christ.
You died, you don't live anymore.
And so we need to move with Him.
Would you close our eyes in prayer?
Yeah sure.
Close our eyes.
Lord, just thank you for this great message Lord.
Just the reminder again that this road of
sanctification that we're on Lord is not a road
that has an ending. but it's a path and in a road
that we will need to walk until the day that
we die as Jaques also said help us to take it
to heart help us to implement these things that
we discuss in our own lives as well so that in
order of us doing so that we can be an example
for those around us what it means to live holy.
Amen.
Thank you so much.
Let's start with the standup.
So there's a few things we need to talk about but
before we talk about the editors and after that
the marketing and social media and everything else
(two hours later) okay, cool, alright, okay bye.
Wow it's after 12:00 sometimes that's how it goes
uh it's after 12:00 already I'm going to head to
the gym because I made it a point to really take
care of my body and so it's something that
I need to do and Jacques, Caline and Nikita
are going to join me.
Yes, are you ready?
I'm ready for the gym.
Nikita you ready for the gym?
Caline you ready?
Let's go.
You need your phone?
Okay, go get your phone Caline.
I'm going to drive away.
Daniel, Caline is taking too long.
That's it.
If you snooze you lose.
Sorry Caline.
Goodbye
Where is she?
You need to be fast... watch
out, watch out, watch out.
And you got my water, thank you.
Good job Caline.
Let's go.
These people are still busy building, my goodness.
This is where all the noise comes from.
The noise comes from, right Daniel?
Yeah, when you want to film videos and then
when you're ready everything is set camera
is set you make time for it and then when you
just say, Hey, welcome to DLM Men's Lifestyle,
you hear (construction noises).
The problems of content creators.
Anyway, let's do this.
Let's get to the gym.
Alright here we are.
Let's get crackin'.
Crackin'
Woo, that was a workout.
So Nikita and them, they're not done yet.
So I came to the car to quickly see if I can
quickly reply to a few people voice messages
and normal messages and just do a bit of admin
because um it's the first time that I looked
at my phone today and it's just going so busy
every day that you have to take these moments
and use every minute that you have effectively so
I'm going to sit here while I wait for them it's
too noisy inside and it's it's quicker for me to
just to answer with a voice message than just to
set and type so that's what I'm going to do now
and then uh I might even ask Nikita or one of
them to drive us back home - it's around 20
minutes - so that I can still do some work.
Good to hear from you.
It's been a while.
Apologies that I'm only replying to you now
You guys done? Who's going to drive?
Will you drive or you?
Thanks Jaques.
Nikita how you feeling?
They look dead.
That is what the air bike does to you now I
sounded like a proper South African. Air bike
real love relationship.
I'm dying.
Don't want to get sweat on your seats.
Oh thank you.
Okay, said oh so you see we we we just arrived
at the car and it's already admin already like
houses and stuff and looking at different rents
and all these kind of stuff it doesn't stop yeah
work work work work work no excuses only results
I like it I like it Nikita more passion more
passion more energy more energy more footwork
more footwork more DLM work more DLM work.
Yeah, so we're going to work a little bit in this
20 minutes and I'll see you back at the house.
Bye.
And we are home.
I got to hit the shower.
I only have 30 minutes before the next
meeting so when it comes to grooming
and everything else I usually just use geology.
There's a lot of other products as well I'll add
everything for you in the video description.
So this takes care of my hair.
This takes care of my face and my body.
Geology is special.
I'm just going to get a towel and stuff.
Geology is special because it's
specifically uniquely designed -
formulated for your unique skin.
So for me I've got dark circles -
I've got the pores here on my nose
which I don't like.
Sometimes pimples.
And so this takes care of everything.
And also I'm getting older.
I'm 37 now so it helps me with
wrinkles and stuff as well.
The cool thing about it is
that it's a subscription
so they just send it to you every month.
Okay Togo you want to take a shower with Dad?
Oh, one of the best things
in life is a hot shower.
Alright, so for my hair, I just take some sea
salt spray and because I'm in a rush I'm just
going to blow dry it very quickly.
And it helps me to style my
hair just a lot quicker.
Alright, you guys can see
it's a lot better already, just to style this.
So what I usually do is I just use a little bit
of a American Crew and I just put in a little bit
just to set it and then if I really want to I add
a little bit of hairspray at the end.
But yeah, that should be fine then.
Just a little bit of hairspray and that's done.
Cool.
Ready for the meeting and then
the only other thing is my beard.
You know, the beard can be
rough and tough and all over
the place so what I sometimes do is I use this.
This is from Beard brand and then I just use a
little bit and it's basically just the same thing
just put it in there now you can go crazy - you
can do different beard styles like even this guy.
He can do that and just roll it up go old nobleman
like or you just bring it down
and you go more like Viking style.
Anyway I just like to make it normal
- neat - and I think that's fine.
So I'm on my way to the meeting and I forgot
I didn't actually eat anything else except
breakfast this morning and it's already almost
3:00 so I'm going to have whey protein - muscle
tech nitrotech - usually I like to add bananas
and everything else but today I just don't have
time so I'm just going to grab a handful of nuts
and here we go now I'm going to take this eat this
drink this while we
move.
Okay, so the light is a little bit intense
here, so sorry about the video quality.
I'm using the GoPro here and I'm using the camera
here to have the interviews now I just have a few
minutes and I'm going to check in with Danie
and Caline, our marketing manager - social
media manager - because we're looking at getting
someone else that will help us with social media
and we have an appointment with them at 3 so
we're just going to talk about a few things
then we're going to have that meeting and I'll
show you just some glimpses of it here and there.
Oh, just so you know, I need to put on this
light because otherwise it's too dark here.
So this is going to be intense for you to
see but this is the life of content creators.
Yeah, it's intense even for me, sometimes
gets hot in here, but it is what it is,
so we use Discord for all the meetings.
Hello hello hello.
So just so you guys know, we are Afrikaans, right?
Me, Caline, and Danie and so we're going
to continue this meeting in Afrikaans.
OK guys, so now got to jump over
to the next meeting with the guy
that we might use for social media.
We'll see if it is a good fit or not.
So he is also from South Africa
so we'll probably speak Afrikaans.
hello hello
hello I would like to start with
a prayer if that's okay with you.
Amen.
Cool.
Excited.
Alright right, bye all.
Cheers.
Alright guys,
it's another meeting done.
So it's going to work.
We have someone that's going
to help us with social media.
He's going to start next week
so that went pretty well.
Now there are two meetings left for today.
I'm not going to bore you with too much
information but we're starting something else.
A different company called Ruach Entertainment.
And we're working with a lot of people.
So I have two meetings with three people
after that with all the Sherpas, team
leaders, managers as we can call it.
And that's going to be a little bit longer and
then only we're done with the team meetings.
I'm just going to make some coffee but I just
want to hear how Jaques is doing with the editors.
Jacques, how's everything going?
Yeah, it's going good.
Multitasking a bit.
Really.
Are you busy cutting up the
recording you did this morning?
That you guys probably already saw and also on
a call with Sandra one of our video editors a
right I'm going to leave you alone then.
OK so I have a window of time quickly to
make some coffee and then I'm also going to just
take Togo and Chibi to do their thing outside and
then just take a moment to take in the view.
You know sometimes you get so busy with the
rat race that you forget to enjoy life and
just stop a little bit and smell the flowers.
So let me take Togo and Chibi first.
Let's go. Come come come come come come.
You know guys, we have awesome merch of a
lot of interesting designs like this one.
Truth.
That you can get on our store.
All the details is in the
video description down below.
I think we have definitely over
10 let's say 15 around there.
A lot of interesting designs.
Check it out.
I'm wearing one of them as well.
Integrity.
Ah, so good.
Ooh, I just
realized that Togo and Chibi - usually I give
them a snack, you know, every now and then.
But they keep looking at me and I just
realized I did not give them snacks yet.
Togo .. Chibi... I think it's time.
OK. OK. Snacky. OK. We are there.
Alright, let's do this.
That's one for you. Togo sit.
Well done, well done.
Don't eat this.
They have to wait until I tell them it is time.
OK. Well done.
It's time to get back to work.
Nikita is busy here.
Nikita is busy here with another meeting already.
Yeah, it's the 2D Art Team meeting.
Hey guys, I'll blur this if
you don't want me to show.
He's busy filming like a vlog
video of a day in the life.
Here's Caline doing her thing as well.
So I have around 15 minutes so I'm
going to do a few emails and then I'm
going to jump into the next meeting.
This is it guys.
This is basically the life of
a Preacher vlogger content creator and um just
a guy who's who's running two YouTube channels
and all that that includes and then also the the
new company Ruach Entertainment - which is - man,
I'm burning to tell you guys about this, but you
just have to watch because it's going to be big.
Oh it's getting hot - this so strange - downstairs
it's cold and up here it's hot in this room.
according to your will amen amen thank you thank
you okay so here we go another meeting hello hello
hello I like it I also want to pray that you
be with us in this meeting Lord so we can keep
progressing great is your name.
Amen, amen.
I don't know - I think it's a good reminder
actually for all of us just to or just extend
those invitations again to the teams.
Thanks everyone.
Alright guys that's it.
The last meeting for the day.
And it's getting dark outside
and my work is only starting.
I'm done with all the meetings and the admin
and everything I had to do but now it's time to
do my own work - prepare sermons - and also trim
this video that I've been filming the whole day.
But first I need to take Togo and
Chibi to go and do their thing outside.
Peepe peepe peepe - let's go let's go,
It is almost 7:00 here at night.
Man, I just love this view.
That was quick Togo.
Let's go, let's go.
Danie, you are not seeing anything.
What what what's up?
What's going on there?
You're not seeing anything.
It is not an Assassin's Creed mirage on my screen.
Oh man, devil games, Nikita.
It's off time well I need to
test it to see the game functionality and like
the user interface designed to like kind of plan
and know if it works good.
Why do you need to do?
For our future projects -
they don't know anything.
I'm not going to say too much.
Yeah, they don't know anything about our projects.
I know that's why I'm just saying future projects.
Are you guys going to play games as well?
I just need protein now.
Oh you tired.
It's been a long day working with all the editors.
Yeah, I know it's been a busy day.
Me too.
But we still have a few hours of work left.
No, we got a few hours of game playing left.
Maybe?
I like that t-shirt Nikita.
What is that?
Thank you so much.
When in doubt pray it out.
Nice.
Our new merch, huh?
Yes, one of the new ones.
Be sure to get it.
Isn't she cute?
This is my wife everybody.
Okay, I had my quota of English speaking.
Bye guys, love you.
Togo and Chibi food.
Togo and Chibi got their food so I think I'm going
to make something very very quick because I'm
hungry and then uh I'm going to continue to work.
Just going to add some mushrooms,
some onions. then some jalapenos.
Some Biltong ooh look at that
and this is for Togo and Chibi.
Togo. Chibi. Sit. Turn. Nice. There you go.
Now just in case if you don't know what
Biltong is, that's like beef
jerky but just so much better.
Some salt, eggs, going in.
Nikita, are you hungry?
Yeah, not for this.
Your own food maybe?
Yeah okay I think I'm going
to finish my healthy salad.
Okay now this is one of my favorite smoked
chili flakes this is so good oh nice.
Nikita.
Is it okay if I pray for us quick?
Yes, okay since you're going to eat your salad
and I'm going to eat it, this delicious food.
Yes it is.
Father,
thank you so much for this day.
Thank you for all the meetings.
Thank you for all your blessings and I just
appreciate you so much and I know Nikita does too.
Thank you for our marriage.
Thank you for just always being there for us.
In Jesus name, amen.
Amen.
Alright guys, so it is slowly getting
late but I still got a lot of work to do.
Got to trim all the footage that I've taken today.
Got to plan for the next day and um also got to
prepare a sermon that I'm going to do on
Men's Lifestyle and that's going to come
a little bit later and the video is going
to be called how to be a great father.
So I also have to respond to a few
people on Ruach Entertainment - do
a few things there and I'm going to work
until I get too tired and then I'm going
to go and I'm going to chill a little bit
with Nikita, with the dogs and then sleep.
Wake up, repeat.
Let me get to some work.
What's it Togo, what's it Chibi?
If Togo and Chibi want to go to bed,
they let me know.
So I've been working a
little bit late and it is time to go spend
some time with them and also with Nikita
What's it Togo? What"s it Chibi? We going to go.
Let's go let's go let's go.
Togo and Chibi... is it time for bed?
Chibi... look at you Togo.
Alright.
So my night routine is just to use Geology for
my face, to wash it and if I don't have Geology,
well let me just show you first.
Togo.
So this is Geology.
I use this to wash my face.
Put on the cream and then if I don't have
that I would sometimes just use Clinique.
Just brush my teeth, so that's basically it guys.
I'm not going to share with you everything we do
now because now it's me and Nikita
just having some time together.
Maybe even read the Bible together and maybe
even watch something together and that's it.
That's it for the day and
then tomorrow is just repeat.
So that's my daily life.
Sometimes I just have to film,
sometimes I do collab.
Sometimes radio interviews
because of my new book that just came out.
There's a lot of things that I do but I
can't share everything with you right
now especially Ruach Entertainment and
you got to keep your eyes out for that
because there's a few more interesting
things that are going to come.
Next is going to be a men's trip
with Danie and with Jaques, a leadership kind
of trip and we're just going to pray together,
spend some time together.
We're going to do some fishing.
We're going to do some hunting.
We're going to do some men's stuff.
So I'll see you in that video.
Bye.